i've put years of my work i had sweats
into this degree you know i've put
almost all i have
like i'm not i'm not a rich person
and the cost of study medicine is a bit
high too so putting all i have into
something to have it all wasted
it's not a good feeling for anyone i
think
[Music]
[Music]
i see people i came with from ukraine i
see them going on with their lives
and knowing i came from the same
situation as them but having
not having the opportunity at all it's
not being given to me it's not being
even awarded it's not being considered
actually
it's pretty sad
[Music]
we are almost six months into um
past the start of the war
and we have really an unclear legal and
social circumstance for people who are
third country nationals um from
who arrived here from the war from
ukraine and there's definitely some sort
of injustice when you see people fleeing
from the same war and not being treated
equally
[Music]
no matter
the amount of setbacks i face no matter
what it stands in my way i know i am
going to become a pediatric cardiologist
yeah that's my dream